[Music]
so that was always my thinking
um early on is that this is
and and mind you before i did dmt i
probably had like two or three hundred
mushroom experiences and so so that was
the only way that i ever thought about
mushrooms
i it never even occurred to me to think
about it as like some parallel universe
or something like that
until i did dmt that's kind of my view
after that like the super high dose one
i was like i'm
pretty convinced that this is just a
connection
that you've there's formed i'm one of
those people i think of there's some
sort of connection you get
to to like a different thing than this
than this yeah like a weird telephone
line or something
yeah i'm in that category of people it's
like i don't know subconscious yes but
like i think there are things out there
that we're seeing on psychedelics well
if i were to
if i were to smoke dmt in front of you
like right now
i would i would without a doubt um
be like yep forget all the subconscious
stuff that i was just talking about i
i it's i just saw there's something
wrong
with it and no doubt about it
and uh i
for whatever reason and whatever biases
that i have
i i tend to in the integration process
walk a lot of that back and i i don't
know if i'm just
stubbornly um like hyper rationalist or
something in
in that way i don't know if it's uh my
religious upbringing that made me kind
of like a
uh angry uh atheist early on in my life
and and that i have a bit of ptsd from
that that i'm
kind of naturally averse to that
perspective but i also there there's a
lot of things that it doesn't
explain like
you wear headphones and play music
during a dmt experience
why is the music altering that
experience so if you're if you're truly
creating a connection
why is your music here influencing
their entire entire world i'm not saying
that it's not it's just an interesting
question i i'd like that's a very good
point though
and uh and then
the other um
the other aspect is it's weird
that they're always ready for you like
there's always like
a whole red carpet rolled out
and waiting for like hey shane welcome
back or whatever i have not had that
really i haven't done dmt though i've
just done the high-dose mushrooms but
when i
like went out to that other universe i
got
completely ignored right like the purple
lady showed up
i was just there watching what was going
on you know kind of floating around and
they like these beings were just going
about their their business
it looked like i'd been transported out
there or was seeing things but they
didn't care that i was there
that's interesting i've never had
they're always very excited to see me
um and and that was always suspicious to
me that's interesting to hear that
because i
it was weird that i never like caught
him off guard or anything you know i
i was just out for a hike recently and i
went to take a leak and
and you know it's cold out and i'm in
wisconsin and like no one's on these
trails
and sure enough the one time i go to
take a leak some guy
comes around the corner and this poor
sucker trying to take in
nature now has to see my flaccid
shriveled
dick out and and but i've never had an
experience like that with i i've never
caught these aliens with their pants
down
you know i've never they're they're
always
it's so like why why is their world
just like set up and ready to go
and waiting for suspicion every time
that i
arrive like is this how they're busying
themselves is just
waiting till the next time some weird
comic
smokes dmt to come and say hi to them to
give him a bunch of messages that he's
definitely going to forget
and even if he didn't no one would
believe anyway
so it's it's
it's strange um i had
i had another experience uh
and this was i so i i used to take
antidepressants for this depression
like a high dose of ssri and there was
this was when i was young and completely
unaware of anything
and i um i took
cough syrup not you know because i had a
cough it wasn't
to take for fun but i took coughs yeah i
wasn't tripping out on cough syrup on
purpose
but it had dextromethorphin in it yeah
and i went to bed
i took my antidepressants took cough
syrup went to bed and i woke up about an
hour later
and i think what had happened is i'd
given myself serotonin syndrome
but i woke up i had a fever i threw up
and then i hallucinated
and it was the same kind of thing i was
speaking to these aliens
and there were these baby baby aliens
and a mom alien and the baby aliens were
like why can she see us why is she here
and the mom alien was like oh just leave
her alone
and it was and i was talking to these
baby aliens and this mom alien but i
wasn't supposed to be there so the
couple of experiences i've had
like i haven't had welcoming experiences
they've just been i've just popped in
there and they're like
what's happening this isn't supposed to
be here interesting
and here i had written off ssris as
being something that had
been demanded by uh by a population of
people poorly understanding their
emotions and
having a hard time being uncomfortable
things and writing depression off as
a mental illness rather than rather than
something that is maybe clueing you into
things going
wrong in your life but it turns out if
you just mix them with
cough syrup you can see aliens
i do not recommend that is a very
dangerous idea judgmental
that's the trick
yeah we're not recommending that but but
that's a thank you for sharing that
anyway
um so yeah so early on
my my first couple experiences i was
less convinced than the people giving me
dmt that what i was seeing was some like
alternate reality
not that it didn't look like one but to
me it was like you described a flat
it looked like i was watching a movie of
of something and they were like you
haven't done enough yet and i said
yes i am like it doesn't get any crazier
than
what i just saw and they're like no i
don't think you've done enough
and so i went about seeing how to get
more dmt in my into my brain which i
another thing i don't necessarily
recommend and
um i
started considering the idea
of like well okay let's just
let's just take these things for face
value you know
while i'm in the experience and
why resist you know resisting these
psychedelic experiences doesn't do you
any good
it's it
a good heuristic is to try to try to
surrender
and be accepting not every little idea
but
but just as a general rule of thumb and
so i was like maybe i'm resisting
and so i was like you know i'll just
interact with these things and so this
thing that was
uh i was like what are you
yeah and they'd be like oh i'm
everything
and i was like and so like i i do that
you know i have this whole like okay
this crazy experience get done
and i'd be like were they though i have
follow-up questions and then i'd smoke
dmt again
and i'd be like what so what are you
again and they'd be like i'm everything
i'm like i don't think you are
i think that i think that you're in my
head
and that this is classic egocentrism
that everything
when i use egocentrism i don't mean um
like egotistical patting ourselves on
the back
i i mean i mean that by
by the constraint that we only have
access to the information
we have access to we are all born and
come into this world the center of our
own universe
of perception and just as much as there
are
all sorts of interesting things
happening in a town over or in some city
in
in bangladesh or something like that
that there might be lots of
interesting things happen that would be
providing me valuable information right
now i simply don't have
access to information that i don't have
access to
and so my brain has to make the best use
of
the information that i do have access to
which
and so it tends to overvalue say
the things that i'm looking at in in the
room that i'm in
or the conversation that i'm in involved
in and it tends to kind of overestimate
that information and
and there there's no
[Music]
there's no choice but to like the
default being the center of everything
and so i'm like having these
these long like philosophical
conversations with these things
about this and they're like consider and
they're like yeah i don't know
i'm everything and and i'm like
yeah but if say you were inside my head
everything to you
everything that's inside of my head that
you have access to
would feel like everything that there is
but i'm telling you there's also an
external reality
that you aren't seeing that you don't
have conscious awareness of and they're
like
whatever dude i'm everything don't
believe me
yeah they were like they were
indifferent they weren't like
looking to convince me necessarily or
any but they were
you know seemingly they just found my
inquiries amusing